[Music]
Merry Christmas and come back soon hey
boss you know the Christmas baking
contest you're always talking about ha
ha the royal family of Belgravia invites
you to compete in our Christmas baking
competition ok we'll leave it Christmas
is a magical time of you I just wish I
had someone to spend it with Christmas
wishes have been known to come true I am
so sorry no problem who are you Oh Lady
Margaret Delacorte Duchess and Montanaro
Stacy denoble I think we were destined
to run into each other I'm supposed to
marry Prince Edward on New Year's Day
but I hate being in the spotlight I want
to get to know what it's like to be a
normal girl
I want to switch places with the other
switch places I've become you and you
become me get out
lonely be for two days no one would even
notice
Stacy de novo how's it hanging how's it
hanging amazed marches it
I suppose at the time if you say so Oh
who you are Here I am I'm determined to
spend as much time together as we can
over the next few days how smashing you
never burn anything I guess I'm a bit
nervous with the big contest coming up
[Music]
we go alright HIPPA close eye on the
Duchess she seen him something different
oh uh terribly sorry that wasn't very
dignified
it's alright quite liked it actually
Christmas should be about love I've
never seen you so sentimental maybe you
don't know me that well I didn't think
things would get so complicated so what
do we do
[Music]
I don't know if I can shoot this out
everything okay
yep I'm great
you
you